bonjour bienvenue dans un ses caches
confiné mais qui reste un ces caches
tout de même
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler de récession
bonjour thomas bonjour l'idée merci
d'être avec nous pour parler donc de
récession à mesure que la pandémie gagne
du terrain les inquiétudes d'ordre
économique grandissent la récession ne
fait donc plus aucun doute mais quelle
ampleur aura cette crise qui sera le
plus impacté comment se projeter sur
l'après crise voici quelques-unes des
questions auxquelles on va tenter de
répondre aujourd'hui
olivier un mot pour commencer sur l'état
général de l'économie mondiale vous
disiez dans l'émission précédente que
cette crise était comparable à aucune
autre est ce que vous pensez aujourd'hui
encore que certains sous-estiment les
conséquences de cette crise oui c'est
certain l'est estime j'entends des gens
parler de 2008
comme si ça avait un rapport avec de
2008 alors qu'on n'est évidemment pas du
tout dans les mêmes dans les mêmes
conditions
alors vous avez beaucoup bureau d'études
qui vous sort des prévisions qui s'étale
de -10 à -40 ce qui prouve bien
d'ailleurs qui n'en n'ont pas la moindre
idée et je dirais à la limite peu
importe on sait que ça va être très fort
je pense qu'on perd notre temps à
essayer de calculer exactement là
la baisse du pib je vois pas très bien
quoi ça peut servir
sauf peut-être à un dîner après qu'on
filme ans pour avoir l'air plus malin
que les autres mais sinon ça ne sert
strictement à rien ce qui m'intéresse
plus moi c'est c'est presque le profil
de sortie de 2,7 de cette récession
c'est à dire que là aussi je pense que
des gens sous-estiment beaucoup ce qui
va se passer
li pense qu'on va reprendre très
rapidement à
à la fin de la période de confinement et
que les gens vont se remettre à sortir à
consommer et que tout va bien se passer
non c'est pas comme ça que ça va se
passer pour la bonne et simple raison
que vous avez beaucoup de sociétés qui
vont faire faillite
beaucoup de pme qui vont faire faillite
que vous allez avoir un taux de chômage
qui va être délirant qu'on a jamais
connu pourquoi est ce que on part déjà
d'un niveau qui était énorme
donc on n'est pas du tout plat en
situation plein emploi donc on part d'un
chômage qui était déjà très élevée on va
rajouter des centaines de milliers de
chômeurs donc il faut pas imaginer que
ces gens qui étaient déjà comme les
gilet jaune qui était déjà à découvert
le 15 du mois vont après cet épisode de
récession historique vont récupérer par
l'opération du saint-esprit de l'argent
et qu'ils vont aller le dépenser donc
vraiment je pense que la reprise va être
plus que progressive et qu'en plus
aujourd'hui on ne sait rien sur cette
sortie de confinement on sait même pas
quand on sortira est ce qu'on va en
sortir début mais est ce qu'on va en
sortir le 15 mai ce qu'on va en sortir
fin mais on n'en sait rien on ne sait
même pas si on ne va pas avoir à nouveau
une période de deux 2 d'épidémie qui va
reprendre en septembre
c'est à dire qui va reprendre au moment
où les choses vont se normaliser au
moment où les gens vont ressortir au
moment où on va refaire du commerce ont
circulé est-ce que
l'épidémie ne va pas repartir on en
parle il ya les médecins sont pas
d'accord là dessus donc imaginer que
l'épidémie reprennent en septembre et
tous vos petits calculs comme quoi il
aura une reprise ou au q3 et au q4 vous
pouvez les mettre à la poubelle
est-ce que vous pouvez nous rappeler le
terme de récession ce que ça signifie
concrètement certains parlent également
de dépression
on a par exemple bruno le maire le
ministre de l'économie qui a fait un
comparatif avec la crise de 29
ce que vous pouvez nous rappeler déjà ce
qu est une récession ce qui est une
dépression éventuellement si on se
dirige vers ce scénario
l'uci parce que ce que bruno le maire
d'un côté il nous il nous prévoit une
récession de 1,4 1,8 et puis après ils
nous parlent de dépression et après ils
nous parlent de la crise de 29
bon je sais pas je suis pas très certain
qu'ils sachent exactement où il en est
et donc les prévisions de de monsieur le
maire sont plus grotesques les unes que
les autres
donc c'est pas le c'est pas le sujet le
sujet c'est que en effet alors après
vous lui ou lui donner le nom de
dépression si si vous voulez on va avoir
quelque chose qu'on n'a jamais connu on
a un pays qui est à l'arrêt et on va
avoir quelque chose donc on a jamais vu
et et et ça c'est ça vient en plus à un
moment où ce que je vous disais aussi la
dernière fois on n'a pas refait gras
c'est à dire que dans une récession dans
un cycle normal
vous avez une période de croissance vous
avez une période où les sociétés se
refonde la trésorerie se refonder fonds
propres vous avez une période où
les gens refont de l'epargne et donc
quand la crise arrive si vous voulez
vous avez un matelas vous avez des
réserves
là pas du tout leleu la situation est
complètement différent est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles les pib les prévisions de pib
sont sont très inférieurs à ce qu'on
avait au départ on va voir sur ces
graphiques
la prévision de la croissance du pib
mondial qui vous allez le voir risque de
descendre en tout cas ce sont les
prévisions de goldman sachs en
l'occurrence c'est la même chose pour un
certain nombre de pays européens la
france l'allemagne l'italie ou encore
l'espagne pour qui là aussi la récession
pourrait être forte
le ministre de l'économie allemand par
exemple le peter acte mayer estime que
la contraction du pib allemand pourrait
dépasser 8% pendant plusieurs mois on
voit que c'est
ces prévisions sont revues au fur et à
mesure elle s'aggrave
est ce que finalement les gouvernements
ne sont pas en train de prendre
conscience de la gravité qui les attend
mais j'espère qu'ils en prennent
conscience ils seraient comme d'ailleurs
qu'ils en prennent conscience donc mais
je vous dis je pense qu' il n'y a pas un
gouvernement aujourd'hui il n'ya pas
évidemment un analyste de bank qui sait
exactement ce que ce qu'on va prendre
sur la tête donc et et pour l'instant je
ne vois je n'en vois pas non plus aucun
qui soit capable de nous dire comment il
faut faire pour pour s'en tirer
faut bien comprendre une chose c'est que
la récession elle et elle est belle elle
était déjà là avant si vous voulez donc
c'est pas on n'est pas sûr sur un corps
navires us qui arrivent et qui met les
pays en récession les récessions je vous
en ai parlé plusieurs fois par exemple
aux états unis la récession elle date de
là
fin 2018 début 2019 vous voyez si on
peut surtout les indicateurs de fret
internes aux états unis et vous voyez
que en fait il était entrée en récession
alors et comme est exactement la même
chose sur sur les chiffres du chômage
là on a quelque chose qu'on a jamais vu
on est à 6 millions en l'espace de deux
semaines on est à 6 millions
d'inscriptions au chômage aux etats unis
alors évidemment quand quand j'entends
certains qui vous annoncent des petits
replis qui vu comparses à 2008 qui vous
dit or vous inquiétez pas ça va
reprendre derrière et on va avoir des
croissances sur les derniers trimestres
qui vont être de l'ordre de 8% ex tard
c'est n'importe quoi
on n'est pas du tout sûr sûr sûr ça là
on est sur des gens qui n'avaient déjà
pas beaucoup d'argent de côté et ça va
être terrible
il faut vraiment se se dire qu'on n'est
pas dans quelque chose qui est normal on
est dans quelque chose qui est
totalement hors norme et qui pour
l'instant est traité par les différents
gouvernements et les banques centrales
comme si c'était la petite crise est de
eh bien je pense qu'on va avoir de
mauvaises surprises
un mot sur les marchés financiers
olivier sait que c'est évidemment très
fragile en ce moment sur les marchés
financiers je voulais vous interroger
sur les grandes entreprises les fleurons
de l'économie française qui sont eux
aussi dans des situations très délicates
évidemment toutes les situations ne sont
pas comparables mais il ya par exemple
air france accord renault ou encore psa
qui sont dans des situations compliquées
pour nous le maire avait déclaré ne pas
exclure une montée au capital de
certaines de ces entreprises voire même
une nationalisation en cas de danger
avéré pour un fleuron national
certaines de ces entreprises ont tout de
même un peu de trésorerie mais ce qu'on
avait raison d'être inquiet pour ses
enfants
ces grandes entreprises françaises oui
bien sûr que vous avez des raisons
d'être inquiet
une entreprise comme une entreprise
comme air france ne va pas pouvoir
encaisser le choc c'est une évidence
qu'elle sera en faillite
donc l'état l'état s'il ne veut pas la
laisser tomber la reprendra donc chers
contribuables vous allez payer pour air
france comme vous allez payer
probablement pour d'autres pour d'autres
sociétés donc c'est assez c'est assez
classique mais il faut savoir que tout
ce qu'ont tous que l'état vous annonce
distribué parce que de toute façon il ne
sait faire que ça correspond à une dette
et donc cas de l'impôt remarqué une
pause olivia on revient dans quelques
instants pour continuer de parler de
cette crise économique et donc de cette
récession sur l'économie mondiale
on est de retour dans ces caches pour
parler de l'actualité économique et
notamment de la récession qui plane sur
l'économie mondiale olivier on va parler
des mesures qui ont été prises par le
gouvernement français pour répondre à
cette crise avec notamment des primes
exceptionnelles de pouvoir d'achat 1000
euros défiscalisées et exonérées de
charges salariales et patronales les
entreprises peuvent la verse et jusqu'au
31 août 2020 elle peut être doublée avec
un accord d'entreprise et la possibilité
pour les entreprises de moduler les
primes c'est ce qui a été décidé en
conseil des ministres le 1er avril
dernier qu est ce que vous pensez de ces
mesures de la part du gouvernement
c'est toujours facile de demander à
quelqu'un de deux pays
vous allez permettre à des entreprises
qui vont être pour la plupart
complètement exsangue de verser une
prime très bien qui va le faire à part
de deux ou trois grands groupes
qui peuvent le faire sinon c'est pas les
pme qui vont pouvoir le faire maintenant
parler du chômage aux etats-unis vous en
avez parlé déjà en début d'émission les
demandes d'allocations chômage ont
littéralement explosé ces dernières
semaines aux états unis avec un nouveau
record la semaine passée 6 6 millions de
nouvelles demandes c'est ce qu'a indiqué
le département du travail jeudi
les américains pour certains ne
parviennent même plus à payer leur loyer
on est dans des difficultés qui sont
assez importantes pour l'économie
américaine
quel regard vous portez sur la situation
outre-atlantique
si réellement il avait une une
croissance qu'ils étaient au plein
emploi et cetera je pense que les
américains auraient un matelas de
sécurité et or c'est pas le cas vous
avez plus de plus de presque 60 % de la
population américaine qui n'a pas 400
dollars devant lui donc et c'est la
première soit disant la première
économie du monde
donc arrêtons ce jeu grotesque on tape
en permanence sur la chine parce que les
chiffres chinois sont faux mais les
chiffres américains sont pas mieux on va
parler un peu de la situation en france
olivier si vous voulez bien on va
d'abord regarder quelques chiffres
quelques prévisions qui concerne
l'économie en france
selon goldman sachs la contraction
prévisionnel du produit intérieur brut
pourrait être entre 4 et 9 % en 2020
autre indicateur important c'est la
consommation des ménages - 18 % sur le
territoire national ça c'est pour un
mois de confinement est possible et même
probable que ce confinement puisse durer
un peu plus longtemps en tout cas qu'il
ne soit pas levé en une seule fois le
nombre d'embauchés également en france
qui est en forte baisse - 70% alors vous
savez le gouvernement mis en place du
chômage partiel pour un certain nombre
d'entreprises 337 milles entreprises
sont désormais concernés sont les
chiffres qui ont été données par muriel
pénicaud la ministre du travail 3 6
millions de salariés sont désormais
concernés s'étaient 2,2 millions il ya
encore quelques jours
que ça augmente olivier les indicateurs
pour l'économie française vous semble la
plus tôt réaliste où là encore peut-être
ils sont sous-estimés je crois que je
crois qu'ils en savent rien et je vous
dis pour la bonne et simple raison qu'on
ne sait pas quand est ce qu'on va sortir
du confinement on ne sait pas si il va
pas y avoir un 2e 2e contamination sais
pas si on va trouver un vaccin sais pas
si on va pas être dépassée puisque ça
fait quand même des lustres qu'on attend
des masques et qu' on n'est pas fichu de
fournir des masques ni aux médecins ni à
la population enfin c'est géré n'importe
comment et et vous avez des gens qui
pensent que ça va bien se passer
non ça va pas bien se passer en france
les banques
il ya en europe d'ailleurs les banques
sont au plus mal
donc on a un risque bancaire qui est un
risque important
vous avez un risque sur sur votre
épargne qui est un risque important
aujourd'hui je pense que tous les
banquiers se se couchent le soir
en croisant les doigts pour qu'il n'y
ait pas de bank run le lendemain et et
d'eau que vous avez une situation qui je
ne dis est hors norme et qui est traitée
par des gens qui ne sont qui sont loin
d'être hors norme et en france le
chômage risque aussi d'exploser à votre
avis on pourrait voir une augmentation
significative comme sega n'a jamais été
réduit donc oui il va exploser c'est à
dire que chômage en france le chiffre
officiel était autour de 9% le chiffre
réel était
plus proche des 20 pourquoi parce que il
y avait tout le le quasi chômage qui
était qui était bien plus élevé dont on
ne parlait évidemment jamais donc vous
êtes probablement vous démarrez si vous
voulez à 20 et non pas et non pas à neuf
donc et non pas en plein emploi cédric
1,9 le chômage officiellement en france
ombre de chômeurs qui vont arriver mon
faire gonfler les les pourcentages
peut-être jusqu'à 30% enfin on est dans
quelque chose il va dites vous bien que
2008 c'était une crise est toute petite
crise voilà et donc que ça n'a
strictement rien à voir on est dans
quelque chose qu'on n'a pas connue
depuis des siècles et des siècles des
pays
arrêtez l'italie arrêter totalement la
france qui fonctionne à 30 % de ce
qu'elle de stèles devrait l'allemagne
c'est pareil les états unis c'est en
train de ce sahara était enfin imaginer
quand même que c'est quelque chose qui
qui est complètement différent de tout
ce qu'on a connu jusqu'à maintenant
rester avec nos oliviers on a tout de
suite passer aux questions des
internautes
on commence avec cette question de peter
rudd est ce que nos économies placées
dans les diverses banques classiques de
détail française peuvent ne pas nous
restituer le rachat des lignes de
placement courant on a beaucoup de
questions de ce genre olivier avec
également des personnes qui se demande
s'il serait préférable de retirer du
cash
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez répondre à
l'inquiétude de ces personnes ah ben je
pense que j ai répondu il ya quelques il
ya quelques minutes en disant oui les
les banques ne vont pas bien et ne
serait pas étonnant du tout que vous
ayez des difficultés au fur et à mesure
que la crise progresse que vous ayez des
difficultés à récupérer notre et pas
autre question libyenne
les signée olivier sa mare lô dans le
fond ce qui est dramatique écrite il
sait que l'on n'a pas de modèle de
rechange
olivier quelle alternative à notre
modèle en place si cette crise était si
grave finalement et quelle solution
n'aurait pour changer de modèle va
changer le modèle saint waast saint
vaast sujet gg aussi répondu en partie
dans notre dernier ces caches où je
disais déjà il faudrait changer d'
équipe parce que vous pouvez pas
imaginer que vous allez trouver un
nouveau modèle avec les équipes
actuelles qui nous ont mis la journée
donc je je je pense que ça
malheureusement ça ne fonctionnera pas
alors maintenant quelles vont être les
nouveaux modèles je pense qu'il ya eu la
crise nous indique qu' il peut y avoir
un certain nombre de choses qui vont
changer
je veux dire le l'euro n'a pas de la
prade raison d'être l'union européenne
n'a pas de raison d'être
il va falloir quand même se poser la
question de savoir s'il faut pas qu'on
rapatrie un certain nombre de
d'industrie un certain nombre de deux
métiers dans l'est dans les différents
pays que essayer de rendre les pays plus
autonome et qui ne dépendent pas d'un
seul fournisseur dans un seul pays
et qui n'arrivent pas évidemment dans
des dans certains cas à vous fournir
donc voilà enfin il ya plein de ya plein
de questions qu'il faut se poser est ce
que est ce que la mondialisation à tous
crins est-ce que la spécialisation à
tous crins de certains pays est une est
une bonne chose je crois pas et je crois
qu on en a malheureusement un triste
exemple
aujourd'hui donc voila mais il ya plein
de ça ça mériterait sa mairie très
probablement quelques émissions et pas
de 20 minutes mais de deux heures donc
il ya plein de questions à se poser il
ya plein de choses probablement à faire
je lui dis la première me semble être
pour réfléchir à tout ça change et les
personnes qui aujourd'hui sont censés
s'en occuper parce qu'ils n'ont pas
prouvé depuis des années ils n'ont pas
prouvé à avoir été très clairvoyant
merci beaucoup olivier rendez vous est
pris donc pour ses futures émissions
merci de nous avoir suivis je vous
rappelle que vous pouvez voir ou revoir
cette émission sur le site rtl france
pointe et venez idées n'hésitez pas
également à laisser des commentaires à
poser vos questions laissées radis
répondre dans les prochaines émissions
olivier encore une fois je vous laisse
le mot de la fin bien écoutez je ne sais
pas quelle belle profondeur de la
session mais au moins si elle permettait
de changer de modèle et de changer les
équipes ça serait une bonne chose